PETE FRISELLA: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir.
These are live webinars
coming to you every Tuesday
from Google Cloud.
My name is Pete Frisella.
I'm a developer advocate for
Google Analytics and Data
Studio.
MINHAZ KAZI: And I'm Minhaz
Kazi, developer advocate
for Data Studio.
And we'll be talking
about building dashboards
for NCAA March Madness.
PETE FRISELLA: So if
you guys have questions
during the session, the platform
can accept those questions.
And we have a Googler on
standby to answer them.
And we'll also do a
session at the end
to answer any questions
you might have.
So with that, let's get started.
MINHAZ KAZI: Sure.
So before we go into
our presentation,
let's think about why
we should [AUDIO OUT]..
In today's world,
we get a lot of data
from a lot of different places.
We're collecting data,
we're looking at them,
analyzing them.
So people at different places,
in different positions,
will have to use this
data to get insights.
You can be an
individual scientist,
you can be someone working
in an organization,
and you can use this data to
get insights, analyze the data,
and also verify any findings
that you might have.
Data visualization gives you
an easy way to look at the data
and get insights very quickly.
You don't have to
specialize in it,
and you don't have to-- it's
a very low barrier to entry.
And there are tools
out there that
will let you quickly
get into the data,
look at a lot of
data as an overview--
as a whole-- then
quickly zoom in,
filter, and then get
insights from there.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
I think it's a good point to
also maybe communicate around
how that data looks, how it
potentially might provide
some insights to other
people within the company,
or people you might work with.
So really, a really great
way to communicate a message
with people is also through
visualization of data,
to really help them understand
maybe some key points
of something you're
trying to communicate.
So it's a really powerful tool.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
So when you're
analyzing data, you
can either do
exploratory analysis
or explanatory analysis.
And when you're doing
the explanatory analysis,
you're basically
taking your findings
and sharing with other people
through different medium.
So you can take data from
a lot of different sources.
And one of the interesting
sources that you have
is sports.
In different sports,
you can get data
about different things in the
sports, and then look at it
and analyze it.
So recently last
year, Google Cloud
did a partnership
with NCAA where
Google Cloud became the official
public cloud provider for NCAA.
You can find more information
about this partnership
on the cloud portal.
If you go to this link, this
will show you different news
about the partnership, how
NCAA is using the cloud
infrastructure and cloud
services to analyze the data,
getting insights and
implementing those.
And also, there is a
NCAA data set available
in the Google BigQuery.
So this link will take
us to that data set.
This data set basically has NCAA
game data, play-by-play data,
going back to 2009.
And before that, you have
final scores back to 1986.
And then it shows data
about wins and losses going
back to even [? 1894. ?]
PETE FRISELLA: So when you
talk about play-by-play,
this is each event
that's happening
on the court for these games.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
PETE FRISELLA:
Very specific data.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
These are very detailed
data about every event
that goes on in the game.
We can have a brief
look at the data set.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: This
opens up BigQuery,
and you can see there are
a lot of tables in here.
So one table that we'll
be looking into using
Data Studio later is this one.
And this table alone has
more than 24 million rows.
PETE FRISELLA: All right.
So it's a lot of data.
MINHAZ KAZI: That's
a lot of data.
PETE FRISELLA: This seems
somewhat complicated, I guess.
Maybe it's around-- something
we want to visualize might be--
Data Studio is going to help
with making this a little bit
easier to work with, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
That's where Data
Studio will come in,
that it will make all
of these complicated
and detailed big data--
make it easier to understand and
easier to use and get insights
from.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
Because I think
there's a wide range
of people's skills and abilities
around working with data.
And I think BigQuery is very
advanced and very specifically
powerful to do a
lot of things with.
It can definitely be a little
overwhelming for new people,
I think.
And Data Studio can really
help make this much easier,
around in terms of
developing and exploring
the data in a much easier way.
But it's a super powerful tool.
If you're familiar with
BigQuery, it's great.
MINHAZ KAZI: So we have
looked at the data set a bit.
Now, the way to analyze this
data is use Data Studio.
Data Studio is Google's
next-generation business
intelligence and
visualization tool.
It's completely free.
You can go to
datastudio.google.com and start
using the tool right now.
It connects to a lot of
different Google services
and lets you analyze the
data that's available to you.
So we used Data Studio to
analyze some of these NCAA data
sets that we have.
This is one of those dashboards,
so we'll look at it right now.
This opens up the dashboard.
And this is pulling in data
from BigQuery as we speak.
PETE FRISELLA: So
this is live, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: This is live.
PETE FRISELLA: This
shows you BigQuery,
in terms of being able to crunch
a lot of data very quickly.
So this is, like, 24
million [INAUDIBLE] of data.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
Since I clicked
and till the moment
this dashboard became
available, Data Studio
worked with BigQuery
to go through all those
24 million records
and get the summary
and then bring up
this dashboard.
PETE FRISELLA: That's
pretty impressive.
And this is a total aggregate
view of all the data.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: So we have
174,000 field goals made.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: 100,000
field-- so it's a lot.
OK, so it's a lot of
events that are happening.
MINHAZ KAZI: And you can
interact with the dashboard
right now.
So let's say we want to
look at a certain game.
We don't want to look at all
the games, just pick one.
And this will list
all the games.
And this is something
that happened yesterday
at Florida State versus Xavier.
So let's look at that one.
If we click on this, it
will filter the view only
for that game.
And we can see
all the shots that
were made during that game.
The red ones are the shots
that made, but didn't score.
And the green ones are
the shots that did score.
You can also use other filters.
Let's say, if we pick only
the three-point shots,
this will keep
only the shots that
were outside of the shot line.
PETE FRISELLA: So
you should only
see dots around the outside.
OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: Great.
MINHAZ KAZI: And we can go
back and keep all of them.
We can pick a different game.
So let's pick something--
we can filter something.
Rhode Island versus Duke,
let's pick this one.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: So it's, again,
going through all the data set,
trying to filter.
And this is the filtered view.
You can also try to
filter out by date.
Since we picked
only one game, it's
showing the filter for that one.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
It looks like you have
additional data when you hover
over each one of these dots.
Do you get some
additional information?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
So when you're
hovering over a point,
it will give you the
details of that record.
For example, this one was an
event where Darren Russell
made a three-point jump shot.
The shot was made, it
was true, and it happened
at the 7:31 mark of the game.
PETE FRISELLA: That's cool.
MINHAZ KAZI: You can
also look at each team.
We can filter only for, let's
say, Rhode Island in this game.
And this shows us all the
shots that Rhode Island
made during this game.
So yeah, this is one
view of the dashboard.
And we can look at a second
dashboard that we have,
if we go back.
This is now the
dashboard in Data Studio,
but this is coming from
a different data set.
PETE FRISELLA: You know,
again, this is like live data
coming directly
from the BigQuery--
that data set that was
in BigQuery, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah, exactly.
It's crunching all the data.
And this is a comparison
view between two teams.
So you can pick any team
we want on the left side
and on the right side,
and it will give you
a summary of all the data for
that team for the 2017-2018
season.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: For example,
for North Carolina,
you can see they have
26 wins and 11 losses,
compared to UCLA, who
have 21 wins and 12
losses on this side.
And this side, you
can see all the games
that these teams played,
who they played it with,
and the scores of each game.
You should see about 11 losses
and 26 wins for North Carolina
on this side.
And there are
other stats related
to all of these games
for both of these teams.
And you can pick a different
team from here, as well.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
And so this goes back
to your original,
when you were talking about
visualization of data,
being able to, in a quick
glance, get some insights out
of data, right?
Because we have this
huge data table,
this huge data set in BigQuery.
You know, with the report
that you were able to create--
this one's somewhat complicated.
This report, it looks
like it was a lot of work.
I don't know.
Maybe it wasn't.
But I'm going to go
through some demos later.
But in a quick glance, you
can get some good insights
and view of this data.
And that's the power of
visualization, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: So
this is a very--
I think, for people who
are basketball fans,
probably somewhat similar view.
But again, then, it
is a visualization
that you're creating
here to represent
this huge set of data, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: It's
very interesting.
This is cool.
So we can see people are--
maybe North Carolina has
got a good away record,
versus maybe Michigan
has a great home record.
So there's some quick
insights you can get just
by visualizing this.
MINHAZ KAZI: That's
the whole idea.
If you wanted to get
these kind of insights
from the raw data set, you'd
have to write a lot of queries.
And maybe those
wouldn't give you
this whole, complete, holistic
picture at one glance.
You'd have to write different
queries at different times,
get one single point of data.
And if you wanted
a different team,
you'd have to pick a
different query again.
And that would
take a lot of time.
But once you have this completed
solution that you design,
this gives you an overview.
And you can design
it for one team,
and then you can
simply switch the view
and look at the same information
for other teams, as well.
And you can do
quick comparisons.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: Now, we've
seen some examples
of the dashboards, and we'll
see later how we can build them.
But let's talk a little
bit about Data Studio.
As I mentioned
earlier, Data Studio
is the next-generation business
intelligence and visualization
tool from Google.
It's completely free.
You can use it right now, by
going to datastudio.google.com.
The way Data Studio
works is that, first, you
connect to your data.
Then you try to
visualize your data.
And then while
you're visualizing,
you can set it up either
for exploratory analysis,
or you can also do explanatory
where you're trying
to share it with other people.
And once that is
ready, you basically
set up your dashboard
so that other people
can view your work.
So let's go through
these steps one by one.
When you're connecting to
your data in Data Studio,
you have lots of
options available.
You have a lot of connectors.
You can connect to
internal Google data
sources, like Sheets, BigQuery,
Cloud SQL, and Cloud Storage.
Your data might be
already present there,
or your data might be
outside of these sources.
And you can bring in your
data from your on-premise data
source, or external source,
and bring those data
into these sources.
You can also bring in
your existing information
from Google Analytics,
AdWords, YouTube.
We have direct connectors
available for this.
You might also have
on-premise data in MySQL or
[? Postgres. ?] And Data
Studio can connect directly
to those data sources,
to those databases,
and bring the data into Data
Studio for you to analyze.
Now, these are mostly
Google data sources,
but what if your data
is somewhere else?
What if you have to access
your data using a public API?
Or you have on-premise
data that you
can access using a private API?
That's where community
connectors come in.
Community connectors are
connectors for Data Studio
that are designed by the
Data Studio community.
They let you get your
data from any API--
that might include
WebAPI or JDBC--
and bring that data into Data
Studio for you to analyze.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
It's a very powerful feature.
We've seen a lot of
people using this feature
to bring in data that's not
necessarily publicly available.
Maybe it's something
just for your company
that you might have
a specific API,
and you really want
to be able to allow
your users within your
company to analyze
that data within Data Studio.
So this really gives you a great
option to extend the platform
and bring in data that's really
important to your business
or specifically to some use
case that you might have.
And we actually have a
lot built by our partners
already that are
supported by our partners.
But we've definitely
seen a lot of growth
around just companies
building their own connectors
to meet their use case.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
A large number of
connectors have been
built, which has been great.
MINHAZ KAZI: I believe we
have around 75 connectors that
connect to more than 400
data sources right now.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
I mean, the data's the
most important part of it
to start with, right?
Without the data, you
can't do any analysis.
So obviously, this is the
biggest component, right?
Everybody has access
to lots of data.
They're not necessarily
easy to get to sometimes,
but this makes it much simpler.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
And this gives you
the flexibility
to have your
customized solution.
You can bring in templates
that work with your community
connectors and provide you
with a very customized solution
either for your clients,
or for your customers,
or even for your
internal employees.
PETE FRISELLA: So we've
got the data, then next.
MINHAZ KAZI: So
we have the data.
Once you've brought your
data into Data Studio,
you can create some
nice visualizations.
And we'll see how you can
build those visualizations.
Let's say your visualization
is already built,
and now you want to share
your work with others.
How can you do that?
There are multiple
ways available.
The first is you can
just share with a link,
just like Drive Documents.
You can provide people with
view access or write access.
You can also embed
your Data Studio
report as a infographic or
a report in any web page,
or you can use it
as a presentation.
We'll have a very quick look
at one of these examples.
This is a blog post
on the Cloud Big Data
blog where there was
analysis of the block chain
data for Bitcoin.
And over here, you can see there
are Data Studio dashboards that
are working on live data.
And you can interact
with these dashboards.
Right now, we can
pick a date range.
Let's say we can pick--
PETE FRISELLA: So this is
on the Google Cloud blog,
and it's an embedded
dashboard in the blog.
So if anybody went to
this URL right now,
they would see this report,
and they could actually
interact with it.
MINHAZ KAZI: Correct.
Exactly.
And this was made
using Data Studio,
using the BigQuery data.
PETE FRISELLA: And using
BigQuery data, yep.
MINHAZ KAZI: Now, going back--
so let's create some dashboards.
We know how Data Studio
works, so let's use
that knowledge to create some
dashboard that we can use.
But let's try with a very
simple example first.
We'll look at a sheet
that has some data.
So this Google sheet has
data from fueleconomy.gov.
It's a subset of the data
that contains fuel economy
about different vehicles.
This is what the
data looks like.
PETE FRISELLA: So this is just
giving you an overview of,
end-to-end, how the
feature actually works
and the product works.
So we have some data
we're going to start with.
In this case, just
the fuel data, right?
The fuel.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
Yeah.
And we can go Data Studio.
PETE FRISELLA: So
it's in Google Sheets.
There's a sheet of data, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: Now, you're
coming into Data Studio.
MINHAZ KAZI: And then
they're picking--
let's say I'll create a new
report, so Create a New Report.
This is creating my new report.
And I'll create a
new data source.
And I'll peek--
PETE FRISELLA: And a data source
is a connection to some data
somewhere, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: So
in this case, we're
going to connect
to Google Sheets
and create this data source.
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
These connectors
are the connectors
that we mentioned before--
the different data sources
that you can connect to.
PETE FRISELLA: Yep.
MINHAZ KAZI: So
we'll pick Sheets.
And this is the sheet that
we're trying to connect to.
It will give us a list
of the worksheets.
And we want to connect to
the data worksheet-- that's
this one.
PETE FRISELLA: Yep, OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: And Connect.
PETE FRISELLA: So
you click Connect?
OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: Now, Data
Studio went into the sheet
and tried to figure
out what data is there.
And I know that this one
is-- though it's a number,
I want to use it as a text.
And so I'll just change
this type to Text,
and I'll do a quick count
on the number of this.
And then I will add
it to the report.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
So this just represents
all the different columns
that were in the sheet.
Those are your different
fields that you can work with?
OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: So let's say I
want to look at all the vehicles
that were added to the
database and the release
date of the vehicle.
So I will add the count
of vehicles as the metric
that we're trying to use.
And also, we'll make
it a cumulative number.
So we can see that
it's about 1,200.
So we'll also put the
total number in here.
So we picked a line chart here,
which is a time series chart,
but we'll pick a
total scorecard that
will look at the
same information,
but at a aggregate level.
So for this one, I'll pick,
again, the distinct count.
So 1,220 records are there.
And as you can see, it's
a very nice, easy to use,
flexible interface where
you can do drag and drop.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: We can
also create a bar chart.
And we want to
look at different--
here, aspiration method.
And maybe look at
their average mileage,
and make it a
horizontal bar chart.
PETE FRISELLA: So we've
taken that sheet that
was columns of data and been
able to visualize very easily
with click, point, drag, and
drop, different components
of visualizations that we have.
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: Very,
very simple process.
MINHAZ KAZI: And this is
where we're trying to do a--
maybe look at the
percentage of vehicles
that are marked as gas guzzler.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: And we'll
do one more example here
that's a quick scatter chart.
We'll pick, maybe, the
record number here,
and we will do engine
displacement and the mileage.
So this gives us a
nice scatter chart
of all the vehicles
and their mileage,
versus engine displacement.
You can also set up
different colors,
label it using different colors.
Maybe we'll change the color
to represent the aspiration
method of the engine.
And now you can see
a nice scatter chart
that shows the relationship
between the mileage
and the engine displacement.
So this gives us a quick
overview of the capabilities
of Data Studio.
So let's go back
and try to use what
we learned here to create some
dashboards using the NCAA data.
So first, we'll try to create
the dashboard from the NCAA
play-by-play data.
We've already
created a data source
using the BigQuery connector,
and we'll just use that.
PETE FRISELLA: So
this data source
is connecting to that table you
showed us in BigQuery earlier?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: So we
made the connection.
The data source is
already created,
and now we can just
use that data source?
MINHAZ KAZI: Correct.
PETE FRISELLA:
It's already done.
And this data source can be
used in multiple reports, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA:
Not just this one.
So you can re-use
them, basically.
Yeah.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
If You create the
data source once,
you can just keep on
using it multiple times
across different
sources, and you
don't have to reconfigure it.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: So we'll
create a scatter chart.
PETE FRISELLA: Now, how did you
know what fields are in here
and which ones to do?
Did you spend some
time [INAUDIBLE]..
MINHAZ KAZI: We had
to spend some time
with the data set to figure
out which field was what.
And we built the dashboard once.
But at least we have some idea.
So add a small filter that
says "exclude shots made."
PETE FRISELLA: So you're
excluding shots made.
For what reason?
MINHAZ KAZI: We're
excluding shot type.
PETE FRISELLA: Oh, shot type.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: So there are
lots of events in this data.
The shot type means that
if the shot type is null,
then a shot wasn't made.
So we're only trying to look at
events where a shot was tried--
someone tried to get a score.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
So it's important to
look at your data,
understand what is in that
data, like what questions you're
trying to answer.
And maybe there's
some things you
need to filter out or clean up
just to get your data prepared
in a spot that's good for you
to start visualizing, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
MINHAZ KAZI: And we know
that there are coordinates
for the court, so these
coordinates represent
the coordinate of the court.
So we'll put those
coordinates here.
So we'll put the
x-coordinate for the x-metric
and the y-coordinate
for the y-metric.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
And this is a scatterplot,
you said, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: It's a scatterplot.
PETE FRISELLA: Scatterplot?
MINHAZ KAZI: Now, it's
starting to take some shape.
And we'll [AUDIO OUT]
filter for just one game.
So let's add this filter.
And this filter will
let us choose a game.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: Then
we'll do Show Values.
And we want to
just pick one game,
so let's see what game
we can pick from here.
We can view the report.
We can see there are
different games over here,
and we'll try to, let's
say, pick the Penn
State versus Pittsburgh one.
So we'll copy this
value, go back
and say that this
is the value we
want to be selected by default.
PETE FRISELLA: By default?
OK.
And you just drag
that filter out,
and it lists everything
for you automatically based
on that dimension that you
had already selected, right?
The game dimension?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
It's going into the
data set and trying
to see what values are there--
all the unique values--
and spilling that
up and populating
the control over there.
PETE FRISELLA: Yep.
MINHAZ KAZI: And
for this one, we'll
try to also break down the
data by, first, let's say, time
stamp, and then by event.
PETE FRISELLA: And
the event is the--
so time stamp's obviously the
time that this event happened,
then the event is a description
of what type of event it was?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: And the shot type.
PETE FRISELLA: And then we
want to know the shot type?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
And we'll try to do this
average because there
might be same things
averaging over time.
PETE FRISELLA: And so
within the product itself,
you can actually
change the aggregation
type of these different metrics
by clicking that little--
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
So what I'm doing here is--
PETE FRISELLA: --the
shape of the grid.
Yeah.
MINHAZ KAZI: I'm
going here, and I'm
changing, if the numbers are
getting aggregated, how are
the numbers getting aggregated?
PETE FRISELLA: Right.
MINHAZ KAZI: And we can see
there's some kind of pattern
coming up here.
We'll add the image of
the court over here,
so I'll add an image.
I'll select a file.
I already have this
available over here.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: So the court has--
PETE FRISELLA: That's
conveniently available--
the image, yes?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
We just spent some
time making it earlier.
And we'll bring this
one to the front.
And we'll try to
make this look nicer,
so we'll get rid of the--
we know that the balance
for these axes are--
on the y-axis, it's 600, and
on the x-axis, it's 1,100.
So we will hide the axes.
We'll also hide the legend.
And this is starting
to look like the court
that we just created.
PETE FRISELLA: You
had before, yep.
MINHAZ KAZI: And
if we reshape it,
we can see what's going on here.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
Very cool.
MINHAZ KAZI: We can
also change the colors,
to show whether the
shot was made or not.
We can do--
PETE FRISELLA: What are
you looking for here?
MINHAZ KAZI: So I'm trying to
see whether the shots resulted
in a score or not.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
So a true or false kind of
thing, if it's good or not?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: And that's
going to determine the color
of the actual dot itself?
OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
So if I go back in and
choose this, shot made.
And we'll change the colors.
If the shot was made,
we'll make it green.
And if it was not
made, it's already red.
And this is basically
what the game looked like.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: So this is one
visualization that we create.
And we can see right
now that we can
pick different games from here.
We can pick this
one, and that'll
update the whole visualization
to reflect the outcome
of that game, particularly.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
So a couple things to
note here, I guess.
One is the filter was
added, and it automatically
worked with that
visualization, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: So there's some
kind of magic going on there.
That's assuming that these two
things are related together.
And if they work
together, you get
this result, which is great.
The other thing is,
I think, you were
able to build that visualization
actually fairly quickly,
given it looked like it was a
very complicated visualization.
You seemed to know what to do
very well, very quickly, right?
So it seems like you spent some
time with the data beforehand,
right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: So
really, you do have
to understand the data
you're working with,
understand the data set,
and dig in a little bit
and just understand
the questions you're
trying to answer.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
MINHAZ KAZI: You know, we were
able to do it fairly quickly,
but I think it shows,
really, the capability
of being able to visualize
things quickly is definitely
possible.
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
And the other thing
is you can also
use Data Studio to look
at the data itself.
So you can do
quick aggregations.
You can look at
different histograms
and try to figure out,
what does this field mean?
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: Or how
does this column
relate to this other column?
So Data Studio can be your
exploratory tool, as well.
So that was one dashboard
that we looked at.
And then let's try to create
a second dashboard, which
is the team's game data.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: And again, we have
the data source ready for this,
and we'll use this data source
to create the dashboard.
PETE FRISELLA: Now, this one
had a lot going on, right?
There was a lot of different
components that were going on.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
And we'll try to create
some components for there.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
Yep.
MINHAZ KAZI: So let's
create a report.
PETE FRISELLA: Is this the
same table that we had before?
MINHAZ KAZI: It's
a different table.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: It's
a different table
that has information
about the teams.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: It doesn't have
the play-by-play information.
So the first thing we'll do
is we'll add a filter over
here and pick a team.
So if I type "team" here, I'll--
we're trying to look
at different teams.
PETE FRISELLA: So we want to
see team-by-team comparison
and things.
OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
And I know that, by default,
I want to look at Duke.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: And
I'll add a table.
And I want to see all the
games they have played,
so I'll add those
games one by one.
So I'll look at game.
PETE FRISELLA: So you're
going to add things
like the game names and some
attributes of the game you
want to know?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
PETE FRISELLA: Like this is
going to show up on this table.
It's automatically
going to be filtered
by that control you put on
there already, which is great.
MINHAZ KAZI: The score
is already there.
So the game score
is already there,
and we'll bring in
the opponent name.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
Who they were playing,
that's important.
That would be useful to know.
MINHAZ KAZI: And let's see
if we can bring out the date.
And we'll try to
sort by the date.
So as you can see,
this gives us the dates
for all of-- like this is
the information for all
of the games across
different seasons.
And we'll see a little bit
later how we can filter only
for the current season.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
This goes back
like years, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: So there's
lots of data here.
MINHAZ KAZI: Up to 2009.
So this one is here.
And we can see the
last game they played
was March 17, a few days ago.
And it was a good win where they
scored 87 against Rhode Island.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: So we'll just group
these two so that this filter
is applied only to this table.
So we'll select these
two and group them.
PETE FRISELLA: So you can
scope the filtering down just
to one particular table?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: Yep, makes sense.
MINHAZ KAZI: So you
can have filters
at multiple hierarchies.
You can set filters at pace
level, at report level,
also at different element
level within the same page.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: And we'll
make a copy of this
and paste the same thing.
And let's say, for this one, we
want to look at only Virginia.
So we now have a comparison
between Duke and Virginia
on the same page.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: Now let's
add a page-level filter
that will try to give us
data for a specific season.
So I'll try to find this season.
PETE FRISELLA: So we
have two identical--
I mean, you copied the one, you
changed the filter on the one.
And now you're creating
another filter that'll
just give you the whole page?
It's going to
control higher level?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: So we can
see that Duke has played--
we have information
for 182 games of Duke,
and 176 games from Virginia.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: But
let's limit that
to only the current 2017 season.
So we'll pick 2017
over here, and that
should limit everything
down only up to this year.
PETE FRISELLA: OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: And you
can see that, this year,
they played 35 games.
Duke and Virginia
played 34 games.
And this dashboard is, right
now, ready to be viewed.
PETE FRISELLA: Very cool.
MINHAZ KAZI: So we can also
pick different years from here.
You can pick different teams.
If you can-- wait.
Let's say Santa Cruz, and you
can see the game information
there.
They have only one
game over here.
PETE FRISELLA: Very cool.
And this report can be
shared with anybody.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: It could also be
embedded in a website or blog.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
If you want to share
it with someone,
you can just click
this button, and you
can share it with someone else.
You can get a sharable
link where other people can
use this link directly
to view the report,
or you can associate
with specific people,
give them either edit
access or view access.
And if you want to embed it,
we'll go back to the dashboard.
What we have here is you can
go to File, Embed Report.
You enable embedding, and this
gives you a nice little code
snippet.
You can just copy and paste
it into any website that
supports the embedding--
iframe embedding--
and then you will be
able to view and interact
with this dashboard
within that website.
PETE FRISELLA: Cool.
MINHAZ KAZI: So we've
built two dashboards.
We have seen how
Data Studio works.
There are some other
examples we have.
Maybe we can go through one
or two of them right now.
These are billed by
some of our partners,
or some of the
data enthusiasts we
have that have been
using Data Studio.
This one is very interesting.
This one shows log usage in
GCP, the Google Crowd Project--
Google Cloud Platform--
where you can see usage
of daily view, monthly view.
And it's broken down
by different services.
You can go into this,
you can figure the data.
This is already created.
And the good thing is you
can take this template
and use it with
your own project.
You don't have to create
this from scratch.
That's one of the very nice
things about Data Studio
is that anytime you
create something,
you can let other people
take that template
and build on top of your work.
PETE FRISELLA: So you
can make a copy of this,
and then connect to
your own data source,
and it'll work
with your own data?
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
PETE FRISELLA: Because
all the fields and things
will be the same, yeah.
MINHAZ KAZI: As long as
you're using a similar data
set that has the same
field names and structure,
your data should work.
There's one other data set.
This was made by Mark
Suarez, one of our partners.
This is economical data
about US household income
distribution by state.
Over here, you can see
the income distribution
for each different
state, sort of arranged
in a geographic location-wise.
You can see the income
distribution of the east side,
west side, and sort of
very nice overall view that
gives you a complete picture
of the whole community--
PETE FRISELLA: Mark did
some nice work here.
You have the representation of
the United States of America.
And then individually,
you have these components
that are showing income
distribution, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
PETE FRISELLA: So it's a
nice metaview of the country
in that particular data set.
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: It's very cool.
MINHAZ KAZI: And let's
look at one more.
This one came up
new, and this one
shows a new feature that we
have that is pretty cool.
This is data from the
Google Merchandise Store.
This is bringing analytics data.
The nice thing is it's
also pulling in the images.
So if you have image
URLs in your data set,
you can take that
image URL, and you
can render the image in
your Data Studio dashboard.
So for each item in
the analytics data,
they're basically
pulling in that image
and rendering it in
Data Studio to give
a nice view of that product.
PETE FRISELLA: So can we
see an example of that?
Or we don't have
time right here?
MINHAZ KAZI: Maybe--
PETE FRISELLA: OK,
let's come back to it.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
The information's available
on our support site.
You can see how
we can basically--
any time you have an image
URL in your data set,
you can just take that and--
PETE FRISELLA: And
it'll render it.
Yeah, that's great.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
And this one is a
very nice example
where Data Studio was used to
showcase student information
system data that has
school district metrics.
You have days enrolled, how
many students were enrolled,
different combination of
students, the race, the gender.
And you can filter here to
pick up different grades.
This is very helpful
for anyone who
is sort of like an administrator
in a school system.
And again, since this is a
general purpose dashboard,
someone else who has
a similar data set
can just use this-- copy it
and use it for their own uses.
PETE FRISELLA: So
when you copy it,
you can edit it and do anything
you want with every part
itself, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: You can
change things around,
you can make adjustments,
change the data set.
You can see how they
actually built the report.
MINHAZ KAZI: Correct.
PETE FRISELLA: It's
actually a great way
to learn about how
to use the product.
It's something that
we've definitely
been trying to push people to
build more templates, really
showcase what's possible
with their own data.
And it's been working
really well for people.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
So these are the resources that
are available for Data Studio
right now.
We'd love for you to
go ahead and build
a dashboard in Data Studio.
You can go to
datastudio.google.com.
If you want some
inspiration, you
can go to the
datastudiogallery.appspot.com
where we have dashboards from
different partners available.
You can watch some
tutorials on YouTube.
If you want to develop
solutions around Data Studio,
you can go to our dev site at
developers.google.com/datastudio
where we have information
about the community connectors
and how you can build one.
You can also get support at
support.google.com/datastudio.
And let us know what you
build-- any cool dashboards
or any new cool connectors
that you come up with.
PETE FRISELLA: So thank
you, guys, for listening.
We are going to
take a short break
for some questions and some
answers that are coming.
We're collecting them right now.
We'll be back in a few
minutes, and we'll answer
those questions for you guys.
So stay tuned.
Welcome back.
We have a few great
questions from you guys.
We're going to go
through them now.
And hopefully, everybody
will be satisfied at the end.
So the first question
is, "Where do I
go to build my own
data connection?
How long does it
take to do that?"
So the developer
documentation is available
at developers.googl
e.com/datastudio.
What you're looking
for is a feature
called Community Connectors.
And the documentation goes
through how to actually build
a connector, how it
works from end to end,
and how to test them.
And it provides some samples.
We also have a GitHub
repository that gives you
some really great detailed
examples of how this code works
and how you can build them.
How long does it
take to do that?
So that really depends on
the complexity of the API
you're connecting to, how well
you know the service you're
connecting to.
A lot of the work, at least
in my personal experience,
is that when you're
working with a new API,
that's what takes a long time.
It's just learning the new API.
How does their service work?
The actual writing of the
code for the connector
is fairly straightforward.
And I'd probably expect you
would be getting something
up and running within probably
an hour, at the very least.
And then probably what's going
to take more time, over time,
is just really finalizing
that and making
sure it's working
well and testing it,
if you intend to provide
it to others to use.
It's really more around
the quality control there.
So yeah, fairly quickly--
probably like 10, 15 minutes,
if you're really--
if you're familiar
with app scripts,
you'll get something working.
So it's actually quite
easy and cool to play with.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
The second question is, "What
kinds of new fields or metrics
can I create in Data Studio?"
So Data Studio
provides a feature
where you can create
calculated metrics.
And we have more than
70 different functions
that you can use.
Depending on what data
you're bringing in,
you can add different
fields together.
You can do analytical
functions on them.
If you go to the
support center, there's
the whole list of
all the functions
available and how
you can use them.
You can also do some analytical
functions, like aggregations,
percentages of total,
and things like those.
The third question
is, "You mentioned
public data sets on BigQuery.
Can you show how to connect
to them from Data Studio?"
So on BigQuery, there are
multiple public data sets
available for anyone to use.
To use those, what
you'll have to do
is basically go into BigQuery
and come up with any query
that you might want to do.
You can query the whole
table, and then you
can go into Data Studio--
we can show that.
Well, if you go to the support--
OK, we can actually show that.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah,
we'll just shot it.
MINHAZ KAZI: So let's
go into Data Studio,
and we'll try to
add a new report.
We'll create a new data source.
We'll add BigQuery.
PETE FRISELLA: So this
is a BigQuery connector.
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
PETE FRISELLA: It's going to
show you public data sets.
MINHAZ KAZI: So there's
a public data set.
You'll have to pick
your billing project.
You can get the
free billing project
that lets you use the
data within some quota.
You can pick any public
data set you want.
Let's say, we'll pick the
World Bank Health population.
And you can pick which
table you want to look into.
And then if you connect,
that will connect to BigQuery
and let you use the data.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
And also, we encourage you
to go to the Help Center
documentation.
This will also explain how
to do this process, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: And
the next question
is, "Data Studio is free.
That's great."
Yes, it is.
"If I upload my own
data, where does it go?
Is that storage also free?"
So in most cases, the connection
is actually going directly
to the end service.
So in that case, we're not
actually storing anything.
There is some level of caching,
just for performance reasons.
But we actually don't store
anything in that case.
There are some connectors,
like the CSV upload,
or the file upload.
In that case, yes, then we would
be storing that actual data.
And there are some limits.
I think there--
MINHAZ KAZI: It's a 2
gigabytes per person.
And if you upload
your own CSV file,
that'll get stored
on Cloud storage.
PETE FRISELLA: Cloud storage.
Yeah.
Again, if you go to the
Help Center documentation,
around the file
upload, CSV upload,
it will discuss
what the limits are
and where that data's stored.
Otherwise, typically,
it's coming directly
from the service.
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
So the last question
we have is "What
about non-image URLs in data?
Can I automatically link out
to external sources and pages?"
Yes.
You can do that right now.
If you have any URLs
or links in your data,
you can create a table.
And in that table, you can
mention that this field is
a link, or this field is a URL.
You can also use a URL formula.
You can look it up
on the Help site.
PETE FRISELLA: Why
don't we show a demo?
We got a few minutes here?
Maybe we can just show
them how it actually works.
MINHAZ KAZI: Sure.
Let's see.
PETE FRISELLA: Or did I
put you on the spot here?
MINHAZ KAZI: No, we can do it.
I have to find where we--
I have to see where
we can find a URL.
I'll use a Sheets connector
and make up a URL over here.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
MINHAZ KAZI: I'll
just add a URL field,
and we'll just say
https://datastudio.google.com.
And I will connect
to this data source.
So let me go back to
Sheets and my starred one--
Sheets connector.
I will connect to the data,
and I will do Connect.
PETE FRISELLA: So we
have one column URL.
There's a URL in
that column, I see.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
There's just one
record over there.
And this was the URL.
PETE FRISELLA: OK, great.
MINHAZ KAZI: And I'll
pick this as URL.
PETE FRISELLA: So we've
identified this field
as being a URL, in this case?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: We've Actually
specified that, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
What we can also do,
just to be sure--
if you don't want to specify
it as a URL over here,
but you want to manually create
a formula, what you can do
is URL Link.
And we can say--
PETE FRISELLA: So we create
a new field, called URL Link.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: And
there's some functions
that we can use to
actually make that field.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
You can use a URL function.
PETE FRISELLA: URL function?
OK.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yep.
Well basically, since we have
already something named URL,
it's difficult to
use that formula.
We can use just this and see
how we can work with that.
PETE FRISELLA: Sure.
So the idea is you actually
have a field type that's URL.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
PETE FRISELLA: And
so then Data Studio
will know what to do with
that, because it knows
it's been identified as a URL.
MINHAZ KAZI: Correct.
And if I add this--
so this is the URL.
PETE FRISELLA: Yep.
MINHAZ KAZI: And we can show
it as auto [INAUDIBLE] image.
If we view it, we can
see this is a link.
PETE FRISELLA: Can see
it's working link, yep.
MINHAZ KAZI: And
if we click on it,
it'll open the
link in any window.
PETE FRISELLA: Right.
MINHAZ KAZI: And
that's how we can
link to external
sources [INAUDIBLE]..
PETE FRISELLA: And images work
in a very similar fashion.
You would say it's an
image, and then Data Studio
will know what to do with it.
It'll actually render the image.
MINHAZ KAZI: Right.
So for the image, what you'd do
is you'd do this the same way.
But over here, instead of Auto,
you can show it as an image,
and it will render the image.
PETE FRISELLA: And
it'll render the image.
Yeah.
MINHAZ KAZI: Correct.
PETE FRISELLA: Great.
Well, thank you very much,
guys, for the questions.
They were great.
We hope you enjoyed
yourself today.
Pleasure talking to you.
And we hope you
learned something.
And check out Data Studio.
But we want you to stay tuned
for the next session we have.
It's "Deploy,
Monitor, and Optimize,
Developing Applications through
the Google Cloud Platform,"
coming right here
from Sunnyvale.
So thank you, very much.